[Applause]
I know here at a great load kisser
[Applause]
hey I know it's Oscar weekend isn't it
exciting out here we got the Oscars Wow
you know you're here where they you have
the Oscars come on this is a ritual in
America every year we gather to
celebrate films we haven't seen starring
British actors we don't know it's
unfortunately of course this year marred
by the controversy that there are really
no black nominees even though Selma was
a great movie with a great cast it is
nominated for Best Picture but it's a
shame we have to be so tribal you know
like this I mean the blacks are pulling
for some of the gays are pulling for
imitation game and the Catholic Church
is for boyhood not the movie
a lot of great performances this year
you got to say that Julianne Moore who
played Sarah Palin member in the HBO
movie she played Sarah Palin well now
she's nominated for playing a woman
who's slowly losing her mind it's it's
so hard to fight typecast really sucks
but but it's definitely a great time to
be here in Los Angeles not only the
Oscars but the weather we are like
literally the only place in America
where it's nice yeah you know that in
Miami today Miami was 42 degrees for
once the Orthodox Jews with the fur hats
were appropriately dressed